à
et
sprem
[Musique]
on
hamon
bonjour scott aujourd'hui on va par
ailleurs ici strike cible non identifiée
en rapprochement porte-avions le target
et de 0,90
[Musique]
qui est en mission cougar merlyn
mavericks et goose bon dieu mavericks
egos
renseignements à gauche recherche de
cadres contact 20° gauche 30 nautiques
vitesse rapprochement 900 de gaza
water berline tulalip rogers gelé en
contact radar les reconnaissances a vu
courir à toi tu faire rogers bull vide
et je vous le passez à la poêle y porte
avions sicaud strider de 0,3 une piste
possible
a target au cap deux sets zéro on est à
10 nautiques vitesse de rapprochement
la ghost rider ouvrez de 10 gauche au 0
il est prévu qu'au nez des visiteurs
aujourd'hui négatif commandant
[Musique]
wehrlin tu vois si les seuls rogers
booth toi tu voyais très négatif mais on
dirait qu'il est tout seul à cougar jeux
présentés en face à face à attention
mavericks et horreur de ces conneries
jeu contre par la droite et vers le haut
pour voir si les solos
[Musique]
avery 1000 de rang branchements il vient
droiture loup alors coup qu'est ce que
tu nous mijote
il y en a deux
[Musique]
fuite quand j'avais vu d'aussi près
qu'est-ce qu'il faut tous les deux par
ici quelle position 250 nautiques
commandant 250 seulement virer des mois
de la guerre tu prends le bus quand moi
je fais le 2
je suis paumé dans le seuil merde qu'est
ce qu'il fout tu la mairie
bien sûr nous droit dans nos six heures
sacré bon dieu le fumier mme coiffes et
là quelle distance 200 nautiques
commandant s'il passe à -150 troublant
celle alerte 5 immédiatement bien
commander vitesse france en eux la
brique en gage de fées l'accroché radars
on va tâcher de vue pour toi les fois à
s'y accroche pas pu accrocher le renard
pas grand chose mais ça y est l'accroché
y au pays
[Musique]
pensez y dégager troupe les habitants
demain vrai comique de la fuite
très bien et leurs positions 180
nautique commandant pour un relèvement
0,10 cougar il nous a accroché missiles
dit casse toi l'unité sacré bordel cette
[ __ ] mangane
au nom de dieu un mustang de ghost rider
1,7
le fumier m'accrocher il m'accrocher
missiles autorisation de tir ne tirait
pas aux tirs restreint sans plus
je les vois juste en dessous le mix est
parfaitement placée juste dans les six
heures de google ne marche pas il aurait
déjà dû tirer
il peut nous faire flipper mavericks
point de toi dégage moins de ce connard
d'une qu'elle me souviens pas mais leur
serrer à droite mais moi le regretter
j'arrive
patty rayssac fumier on va voir si on
peut faire toujours
parce que c'est comme ça que tu fait
joujou toi
salutations
regardez de dieu j'en rigole dans ma
barbe
[Musique]
c'est ainsi c'est génial maire daniel
poteau rate mon regard d'éclat à 6h le
mieux dégager
regard ses mavericks voile assez rigolé
pour aujourd'hui ne voit pas j'arrive un
peu de chance d'être en allant va entrer
franquin sur le pont
ja on est complètement le faut ce bar et
cougar
car on n'a plus les minima
o'gara mes doigts ghoga
mais sur le bâtiment
rick a ramené sur le pont dès que
possible les sur moi raconte pétrole
regard il faut poser dont bordel on a
bouffé tout nos sécurités tu comprends
oui ou merde ça va
maverick tait à trois quart no tricks
rappel sur la pente rogers mavericks sur
la porte
vas-y bon dieu on est con pétrole au
monde et ce bordel
[Musique]
sacré bon tu ça alors mais qu'est ce que
tu fous pour la paix instituée pour bar
cherché cougar
lui de poser cet appareil et c'est un
ordre en soin de vous avez pas interposé
pour immédiatement
vous auriez pas vu un porte-avions dans
les parages avec on a un petit problème
par ici le mig lamy dans le cirage je
crois pas qu'il te ramener là lyon
on va bien vous bien
mme ashton dans mon aise je te ramène
comme une mariée lac à rester avec moi
vous
c'est tout bon goût garde une petite
promenade de santé
là un peu pas ghoga a raté par
l'attention
il remonte à poil dans le monde
ghoga
la voilà
tout y est presque parfait mais vous
êtes un peu pas sur le cloud le droit
canonique et rappeler visuel rogers en
visuel
[Musique]
vendredi m
c'est trop bon gars
mettez les gars